hey what's up guys my name is jonah
welcome back to the game engine series
so lately you guys have really been
digging this kind of live programming
live coding thing so we're going to
continue on with that today
hopefully talk about textures assets
loading stuff from the content browser
materials there's a whole
bunch of things that we're kind of in
the thick of at the moment which is i
guess pretty
exciting also a lot of work ahead of
ourselves so last time we of course what
we're talking about the content browser
i'll have that video linked up there we
were able to drag and drop
scenes to load them into the content
browser
and today we're going to just continue
on and talk about how we can basically
do the same thing with texture so i want
to be able to
load to click and drag in a texture from
the content browser
into our actual scene or specifically
onto an entity and the way this is going
to work is
we're going to do it in a bit of an
intermediate fashion i guess today
because
uh you know the way that we want to get
into things is probably like we want to
be able to drag and drop those textures
into specifically materials
right so if we have a texture we want it
to appear on an entity like
on us on like on our sprite renderer
that we have we should be setting a
material to that
but we also need to think about what a
material means because
we are a little bit in like in like a 2d
rendering
situation here and the way that
materials work for 2d rendering is
usually very different
than the way that materials work for 3d
rendering so we really need to think
about the architecture of that as well
lots of things to unpack and discuss
forgive the mess that you see in the
background here today we've just been
kind of reorganizing the office a little
bit
let's dive in and take a look at this
pink cube
and all the amazing things we can do
with it so if you take a look at these
actual
um things by the way if i'm going a
little bit quick i apologize
i literally was recording for like five
minutes or talking for five minutes
before i realized i didn't even hit the
record button
so this is actually my second time
running through all this complete
disaster as usual
live coding am i right anyway so we have
um
we have this kind of uh scene here which
is made up of three different
uh i guess sprites that we're rendering
here sprites because like i mean if you
think about what these actually are
they're just quads
they've they've been given a color this
is not some kind of cube object they're
just quads
we have the ability to obviously change
the color and set it to anything we want
colors are a little bit lame we want to
be able to
deal with textures as well so if we come
in and we take a look at the textures we
have available we obviously have like
the
the ability to be able to actually
render textures
as part of like our shader inside our
graphics pipeline that's totally there
in fact at the moment i believe we're
just constantly submitting a white
texture for all of these because they
don't have a texture at all
and then we're multiplying that texture
with the actual color
so in other words if we had set a color
to something other than white and we
then supplied a texture it would just
tint the texture
so that's our current workflow the only
problem is that we don't have the
ability to actually submit
one of our textures and that's what
we're going to add today
now we actually are going to
have to probably take this back a notch
eventually
and talk about and have a little bit of
a planning episode again because
like i it how we progress with these
textures how we progress with these
materials that we're about to
kind of dive into how we progress with
assets as well because we're getting to
the point where we really need to start
actually having an asset manager and not
just dealing with
data and memory and and textures as they
are right
so um what we need to do is kind of back
this up and i'll probably do this in in
the coming few episodes
and think about like the direction of
this engine and i have some ideas for
that
some of you are not going to like it but
i i
like what we'll we'll think about and by
this i mean like specifically the the
game engine series version of hazel
but the way that we structure this is
going to be important because
we need to think about what part of the
engine we're really working on
and and how we're actually going to
move this into into like a production
environment so
um the thing is like again this is not
like a
it's not meant to be a graphic series
it's not meant to be like a
you know a series in which i teach you
guys how to specifically
work on the graphics the rendering part
of game engines yes rendering is a huge
part of it
but we also have to worry about like
what it takes to actually make a game
and there's a whole lot more to making a
game an arbitrary game than there is uh
like in terms of rendering so rendering
is great and all
but we also need to think about getting
from point a to point b and the goal of
this series fundamentally is to make a
game
and so because of that i don't really
like as you know
we've decided to kind of focus on 2d
stuff first so that we can get to that
end game sooner instead of having to
worry about
spending like a couple years setting up
a 3d renderer and then
being able to make a game on top of that
so because we're not really going in the
3d direction at the moment
we do want to we do we do kind of
not really need the a lot of the
kind of infrastructure and engine kind
of um
design i guess that you would actually
need for 3d so a good example is
materials
right if you are focused on a 2d
renderer
you don't really need materials you can
emulate like the idea of materials
but if everything is 2d then everything
you do
right of course you can have custom
shaders and particle effects and a whole
bunch of other things which i really
want to have i want to kind of build
even though we are kind of working on a
2d renderer here i know it looks
deceiving because this is in 3d space
everything is in 3d space though that's
why
but the point is um you know even though
we're building a 2d renderer i do
want it to still be able to be
really nice right like i want it to look
good i want it to have
particles i want it to have post
processing effects right i don't want it
to just be
a pixel art style 2d engine right and so
because of that we are going to have to
supply some kind of way to be able to
create potentially an entity that has a
custom shader a custom
material so we will discuss materials to
some extent
but when we look at sprite renderer to
me that says
this doesn't need to have a material on
it because everything flows through that
single shader at the moment there's
going to be like an uber shader that is
like our 2d batch renderer shader
and then that is just gonna that's gonna
everything's gonna flow through that
and since everything is gonna flow
through that we can just
expose essentially the uniforms or the
data that comes along with that shader
including like the resources like the
textures
we can expose all that through for
example this sprite renderer component
now we may want to make like a material
that contains a color
and a texture so that we can reuse that
for multiple 2d objects in fact i should
probably look at unities and unreals
like
2d rendering and how they deal with
materials maybe some of you guys can
fill me in in the comments section
below because i haven't really used
those engines much to create
2d games usually like any kind of 2d
stuff that i've done has always just
been from scratch so
um that's actually a good point i should
probably research that but my point is
like let's just say you have two
entities you want them to have the same
kind of texture the same color the same
setup of like i don't know tiling what
else we
support you know all of that stuff then
why would you you wouldn't want to like
i mean i guess you could copy and paste
the entity or copy and paste the
component
but it might make more sense to have a
material asset that you can drag and
drop into two different entities
and that way you can have a material
because i think unity does still have
kind of like materials for 2d rendering
it's just you don't really need to have
them in the sense that like
in 3d like there's a lot of data there's
a lot of
different maps like going on for each
material but then also there are
different shaders for example you might
want to have something different for
like skin it could go
entirely through different shader what
about hair you know that will go through
a different shader
you'll have transparent and like
semi-transparent translucent you know
opaque materials you'll have
you have a lot of different things going
on um you know not to mention like
environment and terrain and grass and
glass and everything you know
so it's a little bit different than what
um we necessarily need to have
inside uh like a 2d renderer so i do
want to kind of
maybe next time it might make sense to
to sit down with pen and paper
or like with a with a drawing board
essentially and actually
think about how we're going to
you know create these kind of 2d
entities and what a good workflow for
materials would be
um it'd be nice actually to be able to
uh also preview these as thumbnails
that would be kind of nice kind of
loading them asynchronously then like uh
caching them into like a thumbnail
database
in fact if you guys want to see that let
me know in the comment section below
otherwise i'll probably um just focus on
the actual game engine
uh kind of side of things but yeah lots
of different directions to go in
uh from here but anyway for today as i
mentioned let's actually focus on being
able to
load um you know a texture
by just simply dragging and dropping it
into a
texture slot over here now fundamentally
that's really easy to do and again
whether or not i actually
end up like keeping that versus
uh you know switching to a material
asset in the future we will see but the
kind of infrastructure is going to be
pretty similar anyway
so if we pop into components and we take
a look at that sprite render component
i'm going to start by just giving it a
texture right so we're going to have a
texture
that we can apply to this um yeah i mean
there's
i guess materials i guess if we're going
for a full-on really cool
2021 style 2d renderer right like a 2d
red 2d plus renderer
we probably definitely do want materials
because i could imagine so many
variations
of things we might want even if it is 2d
so
i don't know let me know what your
thoughts are below and
and we will talk about it but basically
um
so i've got the ability now to set a
texture it's null by default obviously
and so that's pretty that's pretty
simple because now what it means
is that if i wanted to i can just go
into like we don't have a scene renderer
do we how do we render things in this
engine
i'm so used to hazeldev
um so we probably have like some kind of
render or maybe it happens in
on update editor yeah we do draw sprite
and draw sprite doesn't take in any kind
oh okay
takes in a sprite renderer component
okay cool so that means that again what
we could do
is actually draw a quad with a texture
so at the moment draw sprite just draws
quad
but what we could do is if
um if source texture
draw chord do we have a draw textured
quad no we just have a draw quad that
takes in a texture
so that will be let's just copy this
and then that will be so transform
source color what other
things do we have so we have size
obviously
well actually what are the transform
ones texture tiling factor tint color
okay so
texture will be source texture
we'll leave we'll have we might have a
tiling factor eventually but we'll leave
it as
nah you know what let's let's pass an
entitling factor
tiling factor
tin color will be source color and then
we also have entity id
okay so that's good otherwise we'll just
do this
right so technically we could actually
just submit a white texture and run this
through once
but i'm going to leave it at as this for
now so let's also introduce a tiling
factor which will of course will be won
by default
so now going to the scene hierarchy
panel let's take a look at our color
which i think we only have one of yep
sprite renderer component so i'm going
to do two things first of all we're
going to have our texture here
right but we need to come up with a
separate control for that actually
and then over here inside i am gui uh
inside i am going inside this draw
component lambda we're going to also
have that
um and we really need to
come up with something a little bit
better for our ui
because at the moment we've got labels
on the right side and like
i'll i'll end up copying some of the
stuff i think from hazel dev soon
but basically so this will be component
dot uh tiling factor
um the speed will set it like point one
minimum
will set to like zero maximum will set
to like
a hundred maybe like more like ten well
we'll set it to a hundred but probably
don't need a maximum to be fair but i'll
just
leave it at that for now um so at the
very least now we have a tiling
factor now what we need is kind of
like to be able to actually drag in a
texture
so how do we do that well fundamentally
it's really simple right
all we need is a drag drop target here
and again you can set this up however
you like
i'm going to do this i'm actually going
to have a button
right um which is going to act as my
target so this is i think how we do it
in hazel dev
so we we're going to have a button the
button is just going to say texture
right and this is going to be really
lame for now because i'm not like i'm
not
actually styling it at all but we're
going to have a button that's going to
be called texture actually let's give it
a size
so we'll say it's like i don't know what
the vertical height of lines are we
should probably check but for now
i'll just make it like 100 pixels long
and maybe
like maybe if i make a zero it will just
be auto sized um
i need to figure that out
um but basically this is just going to
act the button's not going to do
anything we could get it to like clear
it or something
but this is just going to be our texture
and so what's going to happen is i'm
going to be able to drag and drop
something onto that texture and the way
that's going to work is basically the
same way that we
set it up and edit a layer and inside
editor layer
we had um begin drag drop target
right and we had a payload so i'm going
to call this like asset
basically so the payload is going to be
asset
and then we're going to get a path and
then from that payload because it's
going to be the texture path
and then all we really need to do is be
able to actually
open up that that texture so uh
how we load a texture i mean i think we
can just do
component dot uh
texture equals texture 2d
create and then we can give it a path
which will be this path
now again we're we've got like wide
characters here which is
um uh a little bit annoying i forgot
about this whole wide character thing
but basically we've got path um we can
grab the asset path that we obviously
need
followed by uh this path which gives us
this
and then for now i know we don't have
white characters uh
inside texture 2d so this can just be
our kind of path
so texture path uh and then we can
actually pass in texturepath.string i
imagine
but yes we should probably spend some
time upgrading the engine
and to use these kind of paths instead
of
um strings everywhere okay so now that
we have that g
asset path is one thing we don't have
but we can easily
just and i know it's temporary um maybe
maybe we'll handle well we need an asset
manager first before we can have an
asset path
but we'll just plop that into here so
now we can
actually load the texture and set it
pretty easily so now all we have to do
is go back to
let's see where was this so inside the
content browser panel
and um we basically okay so at the
moment
oh i guess it is content browser item
why would we set it to be asset
everything's an asset so i'll just call
this content browser item so now we can
drag stuff in there
um and it's actually gonna be the item
path so did we just
accidentally make it work without even
trying i think we may have
we'll see how this works so uh
everything is undeclared of course
it is um
yeah that's what i meant so hazel
renderer texture
see if that clears it up
okay so let's see what happens here so
let's drag in that pink cube
scene and then i'm going to select one
of these guys
and i'm going to try to uh
drag in so we can we have this texture
button which obviously does nothing but
i'm going to
grab this checkerboard and drag it into
texture and
my goodness that was amazing
so i don't know to be honest i don't
know why it's all
weird uh
tiling factor works as well let's try
the channel logo
whoa what's going on with this
oh man look it's like half half
transparent
is the image format wrong or something
that's
interesting i mean this isn't
transparent at all
oh but this is supposed to be
transparent actually that's why but why
are we getting all this white everywhere
that's very interesting what is our
shader doing huh
we're rendering with this right
we've got this wonderful switch
statement
color equals text color oh
but what happens wait okay text color
times equals this but what happens
if there's no alpha channel in the
texture
that's interesting
i mean it wouldn't really matter in in
the case of us having the channel logo
so the fact that this is like this is
very interesting
but anyway i mean it kind of works oh oh
oh because it was no because i was gonna
say because it was selected
but no something weird is going on
because look now it's fine
huh let's say the third one
but this one's weird
and now they're both weird okay
something weird is going on with our
batch renderer i think that's fair to
say
but uh you can see that we uh
let's move this let's let's just we'll
sweep that that under the rug
if you know what i mean so we'll um yeah
so you can see we've got our entity now
with the channel logo we can tint it to
any color we want
as you can see which is pretty cool um
so we can do all of that stuff to it we
could even uh i was going to say reduce
the opacity
but obviously the opacity in these parts
is
already zero and but we can reduce the
opacity because you can see we can kind
of see through it now this is going to
depend on render order and stuff like
that
and then of course we can also tile it
so in general
pretty cool right we now have the
ability to easily kind of drag those
things on to change to whatever texture
we want again it's a little bit dodgy
sometimes but we'll
we'll iron out those bugs no problem uh
and
but that's the kind of general idea with
these entities and of course we need a
way to clear them
so yeah really easy to just drag drag
and drop in a texture and
that's gonna be the gist of this episode
hope you guys enjoyed don't forget to
hit the like button short and sweet
today
the way i like things um we're going to
iron out those bugs actually i'm going
to commit this if anyone wants to have a
go at figuring out why
this is this will be a nice exercise
actually figuring out why
we were getting those rendering kind of
errors looks like it's combining
textures i think that
the texture id might be being put into
the vertex buffer
incorrectly or something like that then
open up an issue on
github i will merge in your pull request
i will discuss your pull requests and do
a bit of a code review
in the next episode that could be cool
um
and uh yeah otherwise we'll probably
continue on with having like a bit of a
planning episode
and seeing how we can progress with
materials and whatever else
we need to actually uh start building up
proper
kind of 2d scenes inside um
hazel so thank you guys for watching
don't forget you can help support the
series but go to patreon.com
and get access to hazeldev which is like
the 3d kind of way more advanced
version of this engine and uh
yeah have a great rest of your day i
will see you next time goodbye
[Music]
you